[Music]
hey wisecrack greg here
today we're looking at the show about
everyone's favorite tiny hatted
humanitarian the weird hilarious and
often heartwarming nickelodeon classic
hey
arnold hey arnold stands out among kids
shows for the way it portrays the life
of a city kid every dirty smelly
terrifying second of it on the streets
arnold and his friends cross paths with
grumpy
unhoused people hey what are you doing
in my house
go away face down giant rats
and even get mugged
at home the kids are exposed to neglect
and alcoholism i need a smoothie and
witness scenes of domestic violence
i heard you were at the racetrack i
wasn't at the racetrack i was looking
for a job in the same neighborhood as
the racetrack
what's more the show tends to treat
these things as a backdrop facts
of life to be taken in stride we're not
on sesame street anymore kids
so why does this kid's show make city
life look so dang bleak
and what can it teach us about the way
our environment shapes our lives
let's find out in this wisecrack edition
on hey arnold and
uh spoilers ahead i guess i mean who
hasn't seen this
before we get into hey arnold i wanted
to take a moment to talk about the
holidays
this is the time of year where we come
together with our friends and family
to celebrate the past year and show our
love and appreciation
through the giving of gifts you know
what
that man why should i have to waste my
own money to buy a present for a uncle
that once asked for my high school
girlfriend's
phone number yeah this year gift
yourself with some amazing wisecrack
merch
we've got shirts sweaters hats and mugs
which are perfect for sipping on some
rum spiked eggnog
while suffering through a holiday zone
call and if you order right now with
cold dead inside
you'll get 10 off so take care of
yourself this year
and worry about everyone else next year
or if you want to make santa proud
you can buy some decorative socks for
your little brother if that's your thing
this special offer only lasts through
the end of this shot of a year
so head to wisecrack.store and use the
code
dead inside now back to the show arnold
and his friends grow up in a world far
removed
from kevin mcallister's swanky room at
the plaza hotel
with the exception of ronda and
sometimes helga most of the kids in
arnold's neighborhood come from families
who struggle to make ends meet
55 cents oh they raised the bus fare
another nickel parts of the neighborhood
are run down are completely abandoned
and these crappy conditions
obviously affect the characters
but hey arnold isn't just a show about
city grit as seen by a child
it is in part a show about how the
geography around a person
can shape their inner life and for the
kids of hillwood
that geography is the city itself to
understand this
we can turn to the philosophical and
artistic movement known as situationism
situation is believed that modern life
was as writer grill marcus puts it
boring and therefore wrong that's
largely because it breeds loneliness
and alienates people from each other and
they blame much of that
on city life situation is ghee deborah
theorized an entire discipline to study
its effects
called psychogeography which he defines
as the study of the precise laws and
specific effects
of the geographical environment
consciously organized or not
on the emotions and behavior of
individuals and in regards to the
board's life in paris
the effects were in his humble opinion
not great
now deborah noted as many have that
people who lived in desert areas
tended to develop monotheistic religions
in contrast
he argued that life in certain parts of
paris was conducive
rather to atheism to oblivion and to the
disorientation of habitual
reflexes in other words life in this
city made you an
unhappy jerk and also maybe left you
godless
which we can loosely interpret as not
believing in much of anything
because the situation is weren't so
sacred about organized religion
themselves
arnold's hillwood is quite gritty and
unfriendly to children
pigeons eat from overflowing garbage
cans
subways break down and buildings seem
large and intimidating
also an eternal scourge of rats actually
play critical roles in plot lines
but not in the cool pizza rat way
arnold lives in a boarding house with a
literal sign reading
no kids sharing crowded spaces with
adults
who constantly get into verbal and
sometimes physical altercations
hillwood adults suffer from alcoholism
gambling addictions
and unemployment in one episode arnold
gets mugged and in another he's
assaulted by scary neighborhood
hooligans
and has to be saved by a weirdo
superhero monkey man
the generalized anxiety the kids feel
about their city
is exemplified when grandpa tells them
about a terrifying
hunted train upon seeking it out they
learned that the train
simply transports steel workers proving
that the normal day-to-day city life
can through the eyes of a child be
rendered truly scary
under the influence of a place like
hillwood de boer probably won't be
surprised that many of the neighborhood
children
already act and behave like jaded adults
arnold's best friend gerald for instance
tends to be self-centered looking out
for his own interests at the expense of
others
while he usually comes around his first
instinct is often to take the easiest
most personally convenient route in the
show's very first episode for example
arnold and gerald skipped out on their
roles and held a school play
conflicted arnold tells him think of
helga
and her play and all the kids back at
school that were letting down
what's your point in a similar way helga
takes after her father bob
and holding a ruthless aggressively
materialist view
of the world come off your high horse
sister christmas is about
presence it's about getting as much
stuff as you can possibly get through
these jaded children and the even more
jaded adults
we see what situationist abdel hafid
hatif said
about city life manifested this world
governs our way of being
and it grinds us down even arnold isn't
safe from this threat
after being mugged he becomes obsessed
with learning martial arts to defend
himself and has one telling moment
when he imitates the crazed travis
bickle from taxi driver you talking to
me
fittingly bickel is the character in
cinematic history
most famous for being negatively
affected
by life in a decaying metropolis you're
talking to me
situation is believed that the true evil
of the city is that it's designed
primarily
to serve the interests of business and
when an urban area is developed in
pursuit of profit
which deboer and co seem to think is
true it will necessarily be built to
better
serve more profitable areas classy
neighborhoods with upscale french cafes
equal clean streets flowery medians
and uncracked sidewalks working-class
ones like arnold's
get dirty streets loud overpasses and
junkyards
this obviously hurts working people
that's why new york city's public
transit
is designed to pump workers into a
central hub from the outer boroughs
but not so much for you to visit your
friend in another neighborhood in queens
people like arnold get the short end of
the stick when it comes to services like
public transit this is even jokingly
referenced on the dash subway episode
when gerald points to a maze of maps
tracking the complex circuitous track
the kids must traverse to make it home
oh no we should really be on behalf
what's more there are almost no publicly
owned gathering places
the kids can enjoy they spend most of
their time on the street
or repropriated wastelands of urban
living
like landfills or vacant lots this lot
was full of junk
we found and we cleaned it up and turned
it into geraldfield but it's not all
doom and gloom
the situationists like arnold were
willing to at least
try to look on the bright side the
situation has wandered their urban areas
for days
occasionally months even spending the
night in catacombs
just to mix things up creepy and cool
why they were in pursuit of what
theorist ivan chechaglov called
forgotten desires ours grail puts it
images of play eccentricity secret
rebellion
creativity and negation negation
basically means
refusal to play by the rules of how a
city naturally leads you to behave
how the psycho geography and structure
of it might compel you to
basically they were seeking out signs
that people were refusing to settle for
the condition
awful aspects of urban living and that's
the kids in hey
arnold in a nutshell they turn a garbage
dump into a playground
and dirty streets into baseball fields
and a vacant grassy lot
into a football field though their
neighborhood has almost no trees
they turn the one good one into a dope
treehouse
and protect it from being knocked down
and replaced by our beeper store
these are all examples of what the
situation has looked for when they
wandered cityscapes
they were indeed the board's words in
quest of another use of the urban
landscape
in quest of new passions that is to say
in search of people enjoying their
urban areas in ways the planners had
never anticipated
still for the most part this cityscape
is a bit bleak
but the show portrays this hostile
environment with a weird wonderful
visual style that says
up yours to reality and plays freely
with the laws of physics
more specifically when the characters in
hey arnold are feeling certain emotions
often confusion or fear the physical
environment will shift and change around
them
in order to better reflect those
subjective feelings to the audience
it's a weird reflection of
psychogeography that ends up borrowing
from another 20th century art movement
which also dealt with dark realities of
modern life
german expressionism german
expressionism was an early 20th century
art movement that prioritized
communicating emotions
over expressing realism interestingly
enough
much of german expressionist film was
about making sense of the startling and
sometimes disturbing forces
of urban life often through steep
strange angles
disjointed editing and major distortions
of scale
we see a similar effect in hey arnold in
the opening minutes of the episode
that subway buildings and streets that
are normally straight
appear curved and distorted this
foreshadows the sense of disorder and
chaos
that will take over completely when the
kid's train car breaks down in a rat
infested subway tunnel big open
spaces throughout the show frequently
takes huge artistic liberties with
proportion
shadow and color sacrificing the
illusion of animated realism you
find in a show like king of the hill in
order to more directly convey the
chaotic inner worlds
of its often disturbed characters what's
more
german expressionist set designs in
particular
will often wonky and twisted to the
point of looking like something out of a
pretty dark
dr seuss novel the same thing will
happen in hey arnold
when a character is going through a
particularly airy experience
compare the dark winding tenement
hallways a terrified arnold runs through
in the classic episode pigeon man to
shots from the famous german
expressionist film
the cabinet of dr caligari in a similar
way the ghost story driven four-ride
jack
pulls lots of inspiration from the
laboratory scenes
in the german expressionist sci-fi film
metropolis
and its big haired wide-eyed inventor
character
rottwein who inspired the mad scientist
trope as we know it today
in this darkly rendered cityscape it's
no wonder some kids turn out pretty
jaded
but of course there's one character who
stands out
arnold what a hopeless humanitarian
would a children
jump when an overeager dude despite his
friend's cynicism and daily evidence
of human shortcomings arnold remains
committed to seeing and bringing out the
best in people i'm responsible i can't
just ignore her
of course you can gerald all right but
i'm warning you
this is not gonna be fun the recurring
conflict between arnold's optimism and
everyone else's pessimism points to one
of the questions at the heart of the
show
namely the matter of human nature now
when you live in a dirty dangerous city
like arnold's
you can't blame folks for not taking
much stock in the goodness
of humanity still arnold cling
stubbornly to the belief
that there is good in every person even
if it's been buried under layers of hurt
i mean just because you're not rich
anymore doesn't mean you're a different
person
you were wandered when you had money and
you could still be the same runner now
that you don't
and he makes it a daily mission to find
that good and help people bring it out
in this way arnold's philosophy is very
similar to that of mangza aka
mensches a chinese confucian philosopher
who taught that all humans have an
inherent capacity
for goodness they can grow that goodness
provided they have
access to the basic necessities for a
healthy life
food shelter warm clothing etc while not
philosophical twins
there's still a certain thematic overlap
with our psycho geographers convinced
that urban sprawl was rotting away our
souls
monster famously compared the human
ability to grow in virtue to a sprout
like a little plant just breaking out of
its sea if you deny a sprout air
water and sunlight it's not going to
grow but if carefully tended
the tiniest seedly can become a mighty
tree
in the same way when we tend to our
innate ability to be kind
or courageous or creative that virtue
can mature into a powerful
force just look at jack black
many episodes focus on our boy helping
someone deal with a problem
or behavior so that they can live a
fuller life
consider the time he helps another boy
at school kick the disturbingly
literal addiction to chocolate i need to
get off chocolate i mean
dancing for malta milk balls and digging
in dumpsters i'm like a clown
a chocolate clown but of course arnold's
eternal project the one person whose
good side he sees
but can bring out is helga g pataki
helga is mean and abrasive to the
neighborhood kids
especially to arnold who she secretly
loves
she shoves away anyone who tries to get
close to her sometimes literally
but thanks to his belief in people's
inherent capacity for goodness
arnold senses a side of helga that
normally only the audience gets to see
a part of her that recognizes and is
moved by kindness and beauty you think
you're so bad
but deep down i don't think you are the
tragedy of helga is that her best
attributes are squashed by neglectful
repressive home life which mongzo would
recognize as an obstacle to her growth
and happiness especially in the later
seasons
there's good evidence that helga is some
kind of budding artistic genius
remember that time she memorized the
entirety of romeo and juliet
in one freaking night no sweat i got all
night just for the chance to kiss arnold
with plausible deniability
[Music]
not to mention she's already offering
pointed critiques
a professional artwork at nine years old
you like edward hopper i do
yeah he's okay he's a little simple
though and what's this deal with women
anyway
that's pretty astute for a fourth grader
but helga's parents do just about
nothing to nurture the sprout of
creativity constantly ignoring and even
neglecting her
to lavish praise on her perfect older
sister did you pick up my winter coat
from the cleaners
what oh hell i forgot all the excitement
your sister being home from alaska but
don't worry
because the weatherman said that it
should stay above freezing for most of
the day
it's no wonder helga puts up a front to
hide her sensitive side
if only he could see past my mean
blustery veneer
into my soft mushy interior wherein
i adore him but while the other kids can
dismiss that front as just helga being
helga
arnold gets extremely frustrated with it
he's committed to seeing everyone's
potential for goodness so he views
helga's meanness
as a choice not a permanent personality
trait
why can't you just admit it you're not
this mean so is he right or just naive
and if there is hope for all the wounded
people in this crazy city
what's the best way to help them find
their inner goodness in the long run
the show seems to back arnold's
optimistic view of people
we see this clearly in arnold's
christmas which ends with helga
redeeming her earlier selfish attitude
in this case by giving away her coveted
nancy
spimoni snow boots to help arnold
reunite a family
and though it's never easy the show
depicts many other characters learning
to grow
past their shortcomings and embody their
best qualities
whether that's chocolate boy finding the
strength to kick the beans
a stupid kid finding the courage to
leave his stool
arnold's journey convincing stoop kid to
overcome his fear
is one of the clearest examples of what
the show is really about
namely finding an unexpected solution to
the problems of stress
and isolation caused by busy cramped
city lives
after trying and failing to train stoop
kid to leave his porch
arnold inspires him to be courageous by
telling him about the world
beyond his stoop you may have your
little stoop here
but beyond this stoop there's a whole
bunch of other stoops
in other words arnold seems to be
arguing that the solution to isolation
of fear
the way to bring out our best selves is
through participation in the wider world
and community the one that we're often
cut off from as a result of urban
psychogeography the idea that community
participation is vital for the
well-being of the individual
and that communities therefore have
value in and of themselves
comes back again and again throughout
the series hey arnold the movie which
pits arnold and his
friends against a real estate developer
who plans to tear down the old
neighborhood
and replace it with a shopping mall is
basically an
80-minute screen against gentrification
it's framed here as the destruction of a
valuable established community
from near profit out with the old in
with the new
what's wrong with old things some old
things are great
yeah like mrs vitello slipper snapper
this conflict is very much in line with
what we mentioned before
that whole thing's situation is hated
most about urban areas
the prioritization of profit oversaved
the housing of an entire neighborhood
as deborah wrote in society of the
spectacle urbanism is capitalism seizure
of the natural and
human environment developing logically
into
absolute domination capitalism can and
must now remake the totality of space
into its own setting one major way he
knows that they do this is by building
large shopping centers he wants to buy
up the whole neighborhood so he can
knock it down and put up a fancy mall
this construction project would
effectively displace arnold's community
and if hillwood looks anything like your
typical city
it would fling them farther away from
the city center where they likely work
sending them on farther commutes and
generally making their lives worse
also it would kill a community they've
spent years developing
naturally arnold's horrified because his
community
is an integral part of his identity and
that's actually healthy
according to a group of thinkers loosely
labeled communitarian philosophers
mainly by their opponents in a nutshell
communitarianism pushes back against
classical liberal philosophies
conception of the individual as a
completely separate actor
pursuing their own rational
self-interest instead
communitarianism argues that our
relationships and communities
have a huge impact on our identities and
that we ought to bear that in mind
while living our lives and structuring
our societies
hey arnold seems to agree arguing that
the best way to live in an alienated
world like ours
is to form friendships and families with
the people around us
even if they're just as weird and messed
up as we are the tenants at the boarding
house represent one such improvised
family for as much as oscar ernie and mr
winn and arnold's grandparents may
argue about noise and bathroom access
they also play games together
share advice and even exchange christmas
presents
they're far from a traditional family
but the human need for familial ties is
so strong
that they find ways to make it work even
with all your annoying stinking habits
the truth is
i love you guys the same ethos is at the
heart of the flood
in which the students in mr simmons
class must overcome their differences
to survive a natural disaster and save
their teacher's life
you were together and became a tribe i
am
so proud of you all and in one
thanksgiving special arnold and helga
flee their
family dinners and crash their teacher
mr simmons celebration
but his guests also start fighting and
the kids quickly realize that his
thanksgiving is no better than their own
but even as he admits to how horribly
dinner is going mr simmons insists that
there there's something worth fighting
for
this hot mess of a get together i know
that this isn't perfect but those
special people out there
are the ones that i love and every year
it's my little project to get them
together in a room and
try to make us all thankful for the
things we've got so while hey arnold
does insist that families communities
and neighborhoods are worth preserving
it never pretends that human
relationships are easy the hillwood as
in real life
they're often hard disappointing and
frustrating as all hell
in response to this fact here arnold
takes a sort of fatherless stance
suggesting that since we're all stuck in
this crowd of nuts
weirdos and freaks that is the human
race we might as well learn to be nice
to each other
and enjoy our time together but what do
you think wisecrack
how does the geography around you affect
your life big thanks to our patrons as
always for your support
tap that subscribe button normally like
you've overcome your problems
through the power of community and ring
that bell like it's time for recess
and as always thanks for watching man
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
peace
[Music]
you